[Music]
however that blue represents millions of
dollars and countless jobs and it's sort
of comical how you think that you've
made a choice that exempts you from the
fashion industry when in fact you're
wearing a sweater that was selected for
you by the people in this room from a
pot of stuff that scene from The Devil
Wears Prada illustrates just how
influential the fashion industry can be
and to that point a new exhibit
dedicated to legendary designer
Christian Dior is drawing huge crowds
and rave reviews Holly Williams got a
ticket from London
[Music]
for more than seven decades the House of
Dior has been synonymous with luxury
elegance
and opulence pompadour is the name of
those printed taffeta dress for the
newel flyaway life
now a blockbuster exhibition in London
has brought together hundreds of Dior's
most iconic works
bejeweled and embroidered by artisans
designs that blur the line between
fashion and art everything on display in
this exhibition is Oka tour which means
of course that it's all made by hand
that deal where there are these strong
codes or themes of design which have
really carried through from Christian
Dior's own designs through the seventy
plus years of the house the show also
reveals how deals influence was from the
very start downright revolutionary the
story of Dior began just after the
Second World War an age of
penny-pinching and austerity until a
French designer Christian Dior stunned
the fashion world with his first
collection they called it the new look
Elle magazine's London editor-in-chief
Anne Marie Curtis told us it was both
unashamedly decadent every dress made
from yards of fabric and strikingly
feminine with its Nick Dean waist the
fact that he really embraced women's
curves is is a real testament to the
fact that I think he absolutely adored
women and wanted to make them look
beautiful and empower them the wealthy
and the famous couldn't get enough of
the new look like the Queen's sister
Princess Margaret who wore Dior to her
21st birthday party the dress now part
of the exhibition lana Lloyd was one of
the yours models in the 1950s well what
sort of a man was he he wasn't
terrifying but immediately he knew what
he wanted he had quite a high-pitched
soft voice and he was immensely polite a
gentleman but not everyone was a fan do
yours sumptuous skirts sparked protests
in Chicago by women who preferred
shorter more practical hemlines and this
photo apparently shows a woman being
attacked in the streets of Paris for
wearing one of the ORS expensive designs
though some suspect it was a publicity
stunt celebrity is a still worried war
still helping to burnish it's glamorous
image New York but the house also
pioneered mass market commercialization
producing the perfumes makeup and
handbags for those who can't afford out
couture designs how important has that
model been economically to the fashion
industry Oh
I mean it's hugely important if you look
at the revenue streams for all of those
big brands you know everything from-from
the beauty and again the fragrance and
the accessories are a huge part of their
revenue stream it's vital for a brand
after Christian Dior's death in 1957
other designers took the helm
most recently maria grazia curie
Dior's first woman creative director
who's imbued her designs with a feminist
message but for Svetlana Lloyd Dior
means Christian Dior the man who started
it all he was the first he rarely
changed fashion definitely for CBS this
morning Saturday Holly Williams in
London I love their answer to what sort
of man was he was a little terrified at
this table on a dr well not me
i think what you do is you ask no I
don't think I do I think I would think
you do yeah I don't think I do
I don't I think I'd like to